This child's skill is a
tamer, and the number of stars is a star.Everyone
here in Aether receives a skill when they turn 5 years old.Everyone's
future is determined by the skill they receive and the number of stars.  Why is there no
child star? No star is
deserted by God But why is it here?
Why is it here? Why is it that I haven't done anything? Why
should you never have been born?
You too will disappear in a day.  I was born with destiny,
right? You're my first
friend, so I'll be with you till the end.
[Music] Let's stay together. Thanks to
you, I survived.
Maybe I'm a child you don't need, but with you, that's fine. Just
try your best.  I guess I'll try living my life.My
name is
Bi.Thank you for your continued support.TV anime
Tamer has started a journey to pick up trash
Broadcast in 2024
[Music]
Start
Pupupu
[Music]